[Musik]
ein mann springt sich am vergangenen
montag in manchester in die luft
es war ein gezielter angriff auf kinder
und jugendliche
der attentäter hatte das konzert eines
teenie stars gewählt das jüngste
todesopfer war acht jahre alt
[Musik]
in israel kennen wir das seit vielen
jahren
das hat mit der ersten intifada
angefangen 1988 und jetzt kommt dieses
phänomen auch in europa an
gesteuert vom rand bei ices können wir
etwas lernen als israels
jahrzehntelanger erfahrung im umgang mit
terror
darum gibt es in diesem film
[Musik]
in diesem film geht es nicht um den
nahostkonflikt wiederum seine wurzeln
noch um seine lösung nein vielmehr für
mich die frage nach israel was menschen
in einer demokratie bereit sind
mitzutragen wenn der terror ein teil
ihres alltags wird
[Musik]
jakob perry empfängt mich für ein
interview
perry war 30 jahre lang teil des
israelischen inlandsgeheimdienstes schin
bet sechs jahre lang leitete er die
behörde
danach war er top managerin der
privatwirtschaft später wurde ein
minister im kabinett von benjamin
netanjahu heute sitzt er für die
zentrumspartei in der knesset
[Musik]
kein zweifel dass es noch schlimmer wird
in europa denn es gibt eine dynamik wenn
terrororganisationen etwas als
erfolgreich betrachtet wenn sie damit
panik verursachen können
und wenn die sicherheitsbehörden nicht
wirklich darauf vorbereitet sind
[Musik]
fusion eine israelische siedlungsgebiet
im westjordanland roman hoffmann ist der
kommandeur der sogenannten essen brigade
und damit verantwortlich für ein gebiet
in dem es immer wieder zu anschlägen
kommt
er führt mich zu einer bushaltestelle um
mir die spuren der jüngsten attacke zu
zeigen
eine palästinenserin versuchte hier vor
wenigen tagen in warten die menschen zu
lassen
[Musik]
vor ein paar monaten haben sie bereits
die genau gleiche bushaltestelle
attackiert damals hatten wir hier noch
weniger betonpfeiler der attentäter
konnte einfach darüber hinweg fallen die
neuen pfeiler sind höher und mit einer
unterirdischen eisenplatte an der
haltestelle festgemacht
diese pfeiler zu verschieden müsste man
die ganze haltestelle verschieden
diesmal haben sie gehalten
die kreuzung wird durch schwer
bewaffnete soldaten gesichert im falle
eines anschlags greifen sie sofort ein
das ziel müsse allerdings sein dass es
gar nicht erst so weit kommen
man muss bedenken dass ein anschlag
nicht dort beginnt wo er ausgeführt
er beginnt weit weg zu hause im kopf des
attentäters
internet an orten an denen der
attentäter den anschlag plant muss man
ansetzen
man muss das internet und die sozialen
medien überwachen um den potenziellen
attentäter vor der tat aufzuspüren ich
habe immer potenzial
im juni 2014 versagte dieses
frühwarnsystem drei teenager namens
killertal und natalie wurden hier auf
offener straße entführt
das israelische militär startete eine
großangelegte suchaktion die nation
hielt den atem an
alles umsonst
nach rund drei wochen wurden nahe hebron
die leichen der teenager gefunden
ein ganzes land trauert und wurde sich
ein mann mir dessen bewusst dass sich
nie alles verhindern lässt
gar nicht zu reden von all den
messerattacken aus dem nichts die nicht
regelmäßig vorkommen
arrested in der last ihrer vorhanden
unser geheimdienst hat im vergangenen
jahr immerhin 402 personen verhaftet die
einen anschlag mit einem messer oder
einem auto planten wir haben also
zwischen 400 und 500 attentate
verhindert es ist also machbar
es hängt davon ab wie viel man
investiert und wie motiviert man es das
zu verhindern
die models to prevent dass diese
motivation nach anschlägen auch in
europa sprunghaft steigt zeigt das
beispiel frankreich eindrücklich
wir haben alle maßnahmen getroffen um
unser land zu schützen
es gilt der ausnahmezustand
ausnahmezustand bedeutet und maschinen
können geschlossen hausprediger
ausgeschafft werden
gleichzeitig wurden die kompetenzen des
geheimdienstes massiv ausgebaut
der staat kann häuser durchsuchen und
leute unter hausarrest stellen ohne
richterlichen beschluss ohne anklage
ohne verfahren grundpfeiler des
rechtsstaates sind plötzlich außer kraft
gesetzt
diesen european countries in europe the
justice 11 die menschen in europa werden
sich noch an alle möglichen dinge
gewöhnen die helfen das land sicherer zu
machen
you have to schrie man muss den
sicherheitsbehörden die ihnen diesen
kampf involviert sind freie hand lassen
und man muss ihnen die nötigen werkzeuge
zur verfügung stellen
die europa im moment noch fehlen nach
nine eleven klang es in den usa genau
gleich
die usa werden machen was nötig ist um
diesen krieg zu gewinnen
unsere geheimdienste müssen freie hand
haben um diese mission zu erfüllen
was damit genau gemeint war hat die welt
erst allmählich realisiert
[Musik]
gemeint war zb
und gemeint war nach foltermethoden wie
waterboarding alles im namen der
sicherheit
am ende stellten die usa ernüchtert fest
dass das sie ja ich wollte programm kein
effektives mittel gewesen ist um an
informationen zu kommen vom schaden für
die demokratie
gar nicht zu reden und auf der männchen
eine von europas größten ängsten ist die
moralische integrität zu verlieren
können wir diesen kampf mit sauberen
händen gewinnen
die generelle antwort ist ja sieg wissen
die frage ist allerdings wie definieren
sie saubere hände
ich bin sicher wenn sie einen
durchschnittlichen israeli und einen
durchschnittlichen europäer fragen was
saubere hände sind dann werden sie
leicht unterschiedliche antworten
bekommen
let's face reality schauen wie er der
realität ins gesicht in israel verstehen
wir das sei kampf gegen den terror fast
alle mittel möglich sind das ist ein
feld der brutalität unmenschlich
manchmal sehr böse wenn man zurückliegt
kann man das nicht wie ein chirurg mit
einem skalpell machen und jede bewegung
mit absoluter vorsicht ausführen and
very coaches in evry der kampf gegen den
terror es nicht 100 prozent demokratisch
sein wie ehrlich
aber auch der kampf gegen den terror ins
demokratisch legitimiert werden
in der schweiz wurde letztes jahr über
ein neues nachrichtendienst gesetz
abgestimmt
[Musik]
heute in der arena bundesrat gibt armen
er sagt das neue nachrichtendienst
gesetz hilft der schweiz gegen
terrorismus vorzugehen terroristen
einige staaten wenn du zu neuen mitteln
neue technologie und man muss auch diese
mittel zu unseren nachrichtendienst
geben um diese hoch anschläge besser zu
kämpfen
die angst vor einem anschlag war stärker
als die angst vor überwachung zwei
drittel der bevölkerung sagte ich kann
nicht sagen ob es 1980 prozent sind aber
die mehrheit von dem was die
geheimdienste heutzutage rissen wissen
sie dank technischer mittel technologien
was in israel längst realität ist kommt
auch bei uns an immer weniger
privatsphäre für alle dabei sind
eigentlich nur wenige gemeint in der
schweiz zum beispiel extremisten die in
der nur moschee in winterthur verkehrten
aus dem umfeld dieser moschee reisten
mehrere leute in den dschihad
[Musik]
allein aus der schweiz sind bis heute
rund 80 personen in den heiligen krieg
gezogen
in ganz europa sind es tausende auch der
mensch es traten täter reiste offenbar
in den islamischen staat und kehrte
irgendwann zurück dies ist kein doktor
message to europe das ist eine art
botschaft ein europa das die atmosphäre
in bestimmten vororten in bestimmten
moschee in bestimmten gemeinschaften
äußerst genau beobachtet werden sollte
durch die regierung
durch die gewaltigen flüchtlingsströme
habe sich die sicherheitslage in europa
weiter verschärft sagen die
nachrichtendienste denn es sei nicht nur
hilfesuchende gekommen sondern auch
sogenannte gefährder
von intelligence service big problem für
einen geheimdienst ist das gar kein so
großes problem scheint zuerst einmal
reden wir ja von einer ganz genau
definierten gruppe von menschen des
reitens werden diese menschen in ihrer
neuen heimat von der gemeinschaft
absorbiert in die sie am besten
reinpasse come to exist und community
watch wird das problem ist dass ihr über
die gefährlichen gemeinschaften viel zu
wenig wissen
darum hat europa nun ein neues problem
dass ein bestehendes problem überlagert
europa hat sich nicht so darum gekümmert
wie es nötig gewesen denn es ist schon
bitter
international steht israel massiv in der
kritik wegen menschenrechtsverletzungen
begangen im kampf gegen den terror
die mehrheit der israelis schritt indes
hinter ihrer regierung und wählt damit
auch mehr sicherheit und weniger
freiheit also drehte israel laufend
weiter an der repression schraube dem
eigentlichen ziel nämlich frieden ist
das land der wahl nicht näher gekommen
[Musik]
einer der gründe ist wir haben keine
strategie
natürlich gibt es auch noch andere
gründe aber der hauptgrund ist keine
strategie
jerusalem ein ort der für drei
weltreligionen von zentraler bedeutung
ist ein ort wo nicht nur spiritualität
sondern auch spannungen in der luft
liegen
micky rosenfeld ist superintendent und
offizieller sprecher der israelischen
polizei
sicherheit sei auch eine frage von
genügend personal sagt er
und natürlich entsprechenden kosten
[Musik]
jerusalem haben wir mehr als 3500
polizisten in der altstadt sind es mehr
als 600 an den besonders sensiblen
stellen wie dem eingang zum markt hatten
wir sowohl kameras als auch polizisten
zusammen
[Musik]
in der altstadt von jerusalem kommt es
immer wieder zu anschlägen
darum wird hier jeder schritt
aufgezeichnet solche taten werden zwar
nicht verhindert aber die angreifer
schnell gestellt
auch sicherheitskontrollen gehören zum
alltag in israel
trotzdem gab es in den vergangenen
eineinhalb jahren 300 anschläge 200
attentäter wurden am tatort erschossen
100 konnten verhaftet werden
wenn wir jemanden verhaften dann wollen
wir herausfinden wie kam er hierher hat
er den antrag alleine geplant
diese leute werden sowohl von uns als
auch vom geheimdienst verhört bei
solchen fällen arbeiten eng zusammen
mit erlaubnis des justizministers kam
der geheimdienst bei verhören viel
weiter gehen aus die polizei
when you are going into it jetzt wird
die risiken wenn man es genau anschaut
dann ist es nicht wirklich physisch aber
es hat einen physischen effekt auf den
verdächtigen
man kann zum beispiel 24 stunden am tag
das licht brennen lassen in seiner zelle
damit er nicht schlafen kann oder man
kann ihm eine art maß gehört in von der
welt zu isolieren
so kann man ihn unter druck setzen und
erreichen dass er das zeitgefühl
verlieren oder tut ihm under pressure
denn integration ist aber ein verhör ist
vor allem auch ein intellektueller kampf
zwischen dem verhörer und dem
verdächtigen aspekt entweder fakt ist
wir erreichen in israel 98 prozent echte
geständnisse sind of realtors in bern
hat noch niemand so genannt verschärfte
verhörmethoden gefordert ein euphemismus
für folterpraktiken lauter wir den
besten ruf nach härteren strafen
[Musik]
härtere strafen mögen populär sein lösen
das problem allerdings nur für eine
gewisse zeit denn irgendwann werden auch
terroristen wieder entlassen
auch wenn sie weiter gefährlich sind ein
problem das von gewalt und
sexualstraftätern bestens bekannt ist
und für das die schweiz eine lösung
gefunden hat sie werden präventiv
weggesperrt psychiatrische gutachten die
hohe rückfallgefahr attestieren machen
es möglich
jerome endras verfasst solche gutachten
bestätigt dass er und seine kollegen
neuerdings auch in zusammenhang mit
islamisten im einsatz stehen
es sind jetzt verschiedene forensik in
der schweiz und russland sind involviert
wenn es darum geht gutachten zu
erstellen
islam ist wo potenziell gewalttätig
einer schiene muss aber sagen dass täter
heute das sind eher ausnahmefall
üblicher wies behalten das risiko von
gordon sexualstraftäter und vereinzelt
kurz vor dass halter islamistischer
hintergrund und den wert der beurteilt
genau richten die antwort oder
sexualstraftäter der sogenannte mord vom
zollikerberg 1993 bei dem eine
pfadfinder führerin ums leben kam machte
es mehrheitsfähig dass menschen
dauerhaft weggesperrt werden weil sie
als gefährlich gelten
vor dem trip der erich hauert undenkbar
zeit heißt die devise im zweifel für die
sicherheit
seither wurden entsprechende gesetzliche
grundlagen entwickelt die aber nur dann
greifen wenn wir es salopp gesagt mit
spinnen zu tun haben damit ihren
aufschlag macht er soll breiter oder
auffällige persönlichkeit
ob es gerade frisch wo schwer psychisch
krank ist oder ob es zufällige
persönlichkeit hat darüber haben denn im
einzelfall street aber es ist klar das
sind nicht völlig unfähigen ausglichen
personen muss so schwere ausschlägt
beginnt israel setzt auf andere
spezialisten
wir befinden uns in der anti terror
akademie der grenzpolizei der kommandant
darf sich die persönlich einen lehrgang
in dem neuen strukturen ausgebildet
werden die später alle möglichen
spezialeinheiten auf anti terror
einsätze vorbereiten
das sind keine normalen kriminellen
sondern terroristen
die wollen stärker mit uns oder ohne uns
entsprechend ist unsere taktik wenn so
jemand das leben von zivilisten bedroht
müssen ihn umgehend neutralisieren
[Musik]
neutralisieren heißt töten und das hat
israel perfektioniert seine
spezialeinheiten gelten als die besten
der welt
wir haben viel kampf erfahrungen
traurigerweise kämpfen wir immer noch
jeder hier weiß dass es darum geht
unsere bürger zu schützen
wir müssen nur jeden tag gut genug sein
um menschenleben zu retten
israel tötet allerdings auch präventiv
mit spezialeinheiten und mit drohnen und
mit dem segen der mehrheit
erstens um wichtige köpfe in der
hierarchie einer organisation
auszuschalten organisation
zweitens wenn er eine gefahr ist und wir
keine anderen mittel haben mit denen sie
ihn fangen und ins gefängnis bringen
können also in agentenfilmen und
drittens um zu signalisieren dass unser
geheimdienst stark und bestens
informiert ist also eine art drogen an
dritte große b
wir reden von menschenleben gebaut
jungen lifes das ziel meiner
organisation war es menschenleben zu
retten aber um menschenleben zu retten
müssen andere menschen manchmal ihr
leben verlieren
das ist eine abwägung die man ständig
machen muss 24 stunden am tag in europa
auch in zeiten des terrors undenkbar
fakt ist auch die briten töteten im
nordirland-konflikt gezielt das ist noch
gar nicht so lange her
wie weit sind wir heute bereit in diesem
kampf zu gehen